donald trump's attorney general william
barr is now calling donald trump's
behavior a betrayal of the presidency
and also said yesterday that trump's
orchestrating a mob to pressure congress
is inexcusable
now again the analysis is very similar
barr was trump's unmitigated unrepentant
henchman
for years barr deserves none of our
sympathy
barr is bailing as the ship is sinking
but it's still great to see him say this
former attorney general william barr is
reported by the associated press
says donald trump's conduct as a violent
mob of his supporters stormed the u.s
capitol
was a betrayal of his office and
supporters
barr said that orchestrating a mob to
pressure congress is inexcusable
the statement has been obtained by nbc
news and the associated press was the
first to report on it
uh notable yes do you tend to see
a president denounce their vice
president and an attorney general
denounced the president that selected
them no you don't
and that is significant but everything
that's happening right now is
significant
much of what's happening right now is
unprecedented we are in dangerous
unprecedented times
at the same time bars disgusting barr
deserves to never work again
uh and you will remember that uh
bar resigned last month and uh was
replaced by
by another uh loyalist and um it
happened shortly after william barr said
there was no widespread fraud that had
any impact on the
the results of the election so these are
strange
times but let's not say william barr is
a good guy
um you know people like john bolton and
others who after the fact
say what was obviously true all along i
don't see them as anything approximating
heroes i see them as people who
for as long as it was comfortable for as
long as they could get away with it
they were happy being in proximity to
power
and having access to the president and
having that prestigious title
and then when it starts to become a risk
for their
future their career future their
political future then they come out and
say something like this so is william
william barr is obviously right william
barr is completely right
in saying that what donald trump has
done is a betrayal it's seditious it's
arguably treasonous there's no question
about it
um but the idea that there is anything
uh morally admirable
about what william barr is doing throw
that in the trash forget about it
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity
packed with vitamins a b c and d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video